foreign
how about that how about how I look
though you know what I mean
look at me my hand just propped up like
that look at my hand just propped up
like that you see the tricep popping out
at what extent what accents it what is
it that watch you know what that is
that's burl wood you ever heard of
original grain or do you live under a
rock dude the sunglasses what
I'm looking pretty ill right now and
it's thanks to original grain you wanna
you wanna you wanna up your accents look
at that
it's made of burl wood
burl wood watch it looked tough
especially with the tattoo
originalgrain.com check out these
sunglasses that sold out last time they
get them back in stock and I see people
at shows with the original grain uh
sunglasses and guess what they look ill
too
so
um I wear these
and I'm looking tough originalgrain.com
you guys like deals right well guess
what that's what they're gonna give you
originalgrain.com you can go you can get
all this stuff and look as hip as this
Dad right here
see that propped up the hand just
propped up with that original grain burl
wood watch just killing it's got some
weight to it looking real nice
um originalgrain.com and you use code
congrats and you get 30 off a lot of
these deals they do 10 off but original
grain goes like this
no no no 30 off you need Shades you want
that burlwood looking nice right right
you wear it under your knuckle or over
your knuckle there's I didn't know
there's a wrist that has a knuckle but
either way dude
um
there you go originalgreen.com code
congrats 30 off you're welcome
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the
congratulations hour
this is the episode two I guess I
shouldn't say the title twice but this
is episode 281 of congratulations
[Music]
it's what uh it's you know
congratulations it's what's for dinner
uh no I wish I didn't say that but
sometimes in life things happen and you
roll with the punches
uh Denver I will be there soon and also
actually Phoenix I will or no sorry
Tempe I've got a few tickets left
um for tomorrow night and uh or or
tonight depending on when you listen to
this or yesterday or a week ago
um but Denver I will be there
chrisley.com New York New York New York
February 18th Chicago February 25th I
think probably Seattle almost gone
uh uh they love me where it rains uh
um and then uh Portland I'll be there I
heard it's a mess up there baby uh
uh and so uh and then I got other spots
let's see Albany sold out Lakeland
Florida
uh Midland Sugarland Texas Midland Texas
for some reason
um and then we're adding Austin soon but
be ready though but ish but be ready
gonna play the Moody Theater Moody Blues
whatever the heck it's called I think
it's called Moody Blues or did I make
that up sometimes you make up words you
just say stuff and you're like oh that's
not even what happened at all you know
and then
I told a story about my grandma the
other day and then I realized halfway
through it was like oh this is actually
not what happened and then I kept going
I just forced my way through it and it
was all pretty much just completely
wrong and it's all good life rips while
you're doing that while you're making
mistakes and it continues to rip uh
speaking of which we got our new merch
out there for the holiday it's not
really for the holiday season but you
can get it for the holiday season and
gift it to people the new life rips
colorways uh with that uh with that font
that I really love
um
and you do too because I said so and
we're just trying to build this cult
dude you know the uh the tattoo somebody
just sent me that they got life rips on
the inside of their fingers jeez man
that must hurt
I but they fade a lot right
whatever uh on the fingers and all that
and whatnot
um for me I shouldn't get it on my
trigger finger because of how I make the
gun talk you know what I'm saying
because when I get pissed off right we
don't want me to reach in the back we
don't want me to reach behind my seat
and pull out something that's four
pounds right because it gets itchy right
when you start talking a mess with me it
gets itchy and I said mess not the swear
word because they say in the first
however many minutes of a YouTube video
If you swear then it tracks it and you
know it you get Shadow bend a little bit
what's with the 596 subscribers that we
have on super cult Studios what's with
it dude something's going on
our subscribers we were killing it was
doubling it it was doubling it I came
back to YouTube and we were doubling it
until it killed me that's what Tupac
said not
like someone's gonna
but what's the deal dude we changed it
to Super cult immediately stopped no
extra subscribers in the next seven it's
a conspiracy so what is it what is it
Talk Amongst yourself in the comments
hypo activate that algorithm because
it's like
what is going what is going on my it's
just absolutely mental we stole the 596
when we came back we had like 516 mate
we had like bloody like what
what was it like 80 000 the line like
whatever like a month and then it stole
this soon as we got there and changed
the name Camp what is it the two things
that change or we changed the name and
we added Lifeline uh this is not
Lifeline is a rip roaring show dude
but I digress
so check if you're even subscribed
subscribe again get your friends to
subscribe what's YouTube doing baby
um it's a conspiracy and you know what
I've been a part of conspiracies before
so it's fine I can deal with it and I
can roll with the punches
um but we have a good time here
hey dude
Round of Applause for me also major uh
bonehead move
uh I don't go to the bank too often
because a lot of this stuff gets wired
right because you know
paper gets heavy but uh we
um
I went to the bank and I put it in my
Google my Google uh directions or
whatever it's called
and guess what happened dude a Wells
Fargo came up
and I go great on Santa Monica Boulevard
that's where I go all good I know the
dudes there I know the homies and I know
that
speaking of money I just made sixty
dollars on Shopify but
um
yeah dude and it's like so I I plug it
in and I'm going down to go to Santa
Monica
the the the the the street
and I'm like it says take left and I'm
like that's but that's not where it is I
go I'm like all right let's just see
what they do I take sometimes they say
like well as far they pretend like if
you do it in the Google thing Maps it'll
go in and then it's just like a a
[ __ ] uh what do you call it um first
swear word five thirty minutes in
um it's a uh uh [ __ ] what do you call
ATM and you're like oh for fucksake you
ever do that you put it in the bank and
you're like oh Bank of America and you
go and it's just an ATM and you're like
I wanted to go in so dude they should
specify on the Google but again I
digress and so
um so I get there and it's a whole full
Bank dude and it was closer than the one
that I've been going to for years so oh
dude what a big bonehead move
and I'm pissed but it's okay because
we're stacking yape right so I go in and
the [ __ ] bank the new bank that I'm
gonna go to this is not my home Bank
dude oh it's much closer than the last
one and yeah like the guy who deals with
my [ __ ] he emails me from time to time
you know he's like you want to go over
some more interest rates or whatever
they say I don't listen to the email but
I I always reply back like yeah whatever
my business manager says buddy good
seeing you the other day
but they got a whole bank that I didn't
know about a whole bank that I didn't
know about and so I go in and when I go
in what's it smell like it smells like
eggs and pipes
dude it smells like [ __ ] eggs and
pipes dude
and you know what I'm talking about too
that's the greatest thing smells like
eggs and pipes and so I go there
because this is not my home Bank
and guess what it's next to a [ __ ]
coffee shop Jesus Christ
[Applause]
[Music]
so I'm just like in heaven do it and
it's near a Trader Joe's but it's all
good because I don't go to Trader Joe's
nor do I grocery shop but the talent
there and the chicks that go they're the
eye candy it's ridiculous
but your boy's just looking nowadays
right he's just looking he's like that
emoji like this
but he just looks but it's all good I'm
Not Dead
one time when I was a kid I asked my dad
I said when do you want to stop like
sleeping with other women and he laughed
like hell and he said well I I don't I
mean like I don't know you always want
to and I said really and he said yeah
I'm not dead oh we were at the Dodger
game the memories
but um
so anyway uh I go into the bank and um
and uh smells like eggs and farts and
[ __ ] pipes and [ __ ] sewer sewer
sewage
and uh I'm doing the bank and I'm there
for way too long and it's and it's too
it's too late so I'm in LA on the next
in line I'm waiting too long and already
I'm like pissed off at my new home bank
and then it's my turn and I go in and I
have two checks I have a personal check
and then I have a business check all
right
I do the personal check and they make me
sign in four different times okay so I'm
I say what's going on is everything cool
and they're like yeah sorry it's just we
got the account number wrong and we got
to write a new thing so sign this so I
signed that then
they try to put my business check in
they they give me something to sign
again I sign it they they they try to do
it then I have to sign something else
again and I say is everything okay and
they say yes and then the lady comes
over and this is 25 minutes in I'm
dealing I'm standing at this [ __ ]
whatever it is with the bulletproof
glass and I'm waiting
and this lady walks in and she says hold
on I wrote it down quote quote I would
have done quote she walked in just like
this super sassy beautiful lady like
walked in like you know with big hoop
earrings and I'm not you know I don't
want to you can get in a lot of trouble
saying somebody's race but you know what
race she was just because of the hoop
earrings right well I guess you could
have been Mexican but she wasn't so now
you know what she is and so uh this is
what she said hold on she walked in and
it was just I was getting so riled up
and then because it took so long and
then she goes like this
oh what is this smell it's funky in here
y'all
accident she says oh what is this smell
that's funky in here y'all and I looked
at her and I go yeah and then she walked
by me and she said to the [ __ ] guy
behind the counter he says
are you guys she says are you guys about
the sewer
just so great she says what's what's
this smell
that she said to she after she said oh
what's this smell is funky in here y'all
she arrived at the thing and she said
what's the smell what's the smell it
stink up in here y'all I'ma buy y'all
some Lysol and I'm just finally dude she
came to my rescue so thank you lady
you've got big hook bearings but you
came to my mother who appearance were so
big if she was sitting in front of me in
the movie theater I have to watch watch
the movie through him
um
but yeah do it
it's stink up in here y'all
so I was pissed and then she came in and
saved the day and light in my mood you
know what it is dude I'm my [ __ ] [ __ ]
and I'm not bipolar so chill with the
comments dude you'll guys you know
everyone's always trying to diagnose
like somebody's like oh Crystal you're
the first guy who's addicted to CBD I'm
not addicted to CBD you can't get
addicted to CBD but I love CBD dude and
I'm with that pure spectrum and if you
want it dude I eat those gummies those
gummies are ridiculous I put the dropper
under my tongue and I'd let it sit for
30 minutes for 30 minutes 30 seconds and
I just [ __ ] you know I let it
ruminate and [ __ ] you know I'm just
like I put the drop in and then I'm like
that top note
and it chills me out dude and did have I
had restless leg syndrome since I've
taken the pure Spectrum D CBD and the
answer is absolutely no I haven't dude
so it's working and if you want to get
it the links Below in the show note
description and you can get 10 off by
typing in congrats yes dude and I'm
doing that because you know I started
taking it I like it and they wanted to
partner with me and you know
so get 10 off actually no you know what
they're doing 20 off this weekend I
believe Jenny go check it out
um but uh yeah so
uh
uh so yeah I do but my mood is very
chill but let's get off the CBD talk but
my I'm too uh in my life I have been in
the past two back and forth with my
emotions like something smells bad I'm
pissed off I walk outside it's a
beautiful day and then I drop that and
then I'm feeling good all of a sudden I
gotta let's I gotta be more Zen you know
I gotta just start like I heard a
podcast the other day and they were like
saying something about how we have to
remove want if you want to be like Jesus
Jesus or Jesus depending on how much of
a [ __ ] [ __ ] some ass real ass will
say Jesus
um
but you have to uh remove want from your
vocabulary and your
just you remove want from your life and
I was like man that's like if you didn't
want [ __ ]
how much easier your life would be like
I I see shoes sometimes like I want
those but then when I just sit back and
I'm like if I wanted to remove a want
from my life
there you go I already want to remove
want from my life so I'm [ __ ]
I'm thinking of it wrong if I didn't
want let's just say that if I didn't
want
right
then
how easy would Life Begin the the it's
just tremendous but then you have a kid
and you want their life to be good and
that's a want so it's like that's really
falls on its ass and religion is
[ __ ] all good but don't be mad at me
if you think you know it's like
I'm not outwardly outspoken against this
[ __ ] but it's just like religion is just
like you know what I mean it's just like
between religion you know they they how
they house a bunch of traditions and
traditions or the start of everything
horrible you know what I say on my
podcast like tradition am I on my in my
cult we have no traditions because
Traditions is what causes War tradition
is what causes anger Traditions will
make your dad flip up the [ __ ] plate
on Thanksgiving because it's not going
right and then he's pissed and goes in
his room and they gotta talk if there
were no traditions we would all live in
harmony I'm telling you the truth dude
everyone's [ __ ] crazy religion isn't
saying you know what religion does it
makes people [ __ ] rich but then also
it makes people crazy right so the guy
from Hobby Lobby is not re not leaving
his estate to his children dude he is
not leaving his estate to his children
he's just giving it away dude and if I
was this kid I'd be like oh come on dad
like at least Bill Gates is leaving like
a small amount to his kids which dude
those people are [ __ ] crazy dude man
if I stack
hundreds of millions of dollars if I got
if I got that Hobby Lobby money guess
who's getting all of that yaper dude
Calvin guess who's getting all of that
yaper when I croak all of the people
closest to me dude
nobody else is getting a red scent even
if I start believing dude I could if I
could start believing in all of the Gods
nobody getting a red scent but my
bloodline dude
nobody's getting a red nobody's getting
a crimson scent dude
I swear to God well what about nope what
about the tide nope nobody's getting a
red scent unless they got that Delia
name after it and they're younger than
me or if I die prematurely older than me
I swear to God
I'm gonna leave one cent to all my
enemies oh that's [ __ ] cool dude
I'm gonna leave one cent to all my
enemies I gotta write my will
I really do it's been on the back of my
mind
I gotta leave it to I gotta I Don't
Wanna Die like Philip Seymour Hoffman
and he [ __ ] you know his [ __ ] was a
mess his his estate was a mess because
he didn't have a will
ah
let's not get too dark huh but yeah but
Hobby Lobby guy what's up man people get
so big and so [ __ ] like look at Kanye
dude
CAA dropped him
because he's calling a war on a war for
all the Jews or whatever dude and then
he's like well I'm Jewish that doesn't
work um
well I could say I don't like Jews
because I'm Jewish doesn't work on
hey Kanye you didn't trick us
hey Kanye we could see he's not Jewish
how many times in your life have you
ever said oi
um dude his Piers Morgan interview was
absolutely fantastic but also just kind
of like sad I watched 50 minutes of it
what the [ __ ] am I doing with my life
that I watched Piers Morgan and Kanye
West talk for [ __ ] 50 minutes while I
was on a plane but still dude
because we did
um Raleigh and then uh what do you call
it Raleigh and then um
uh I was in Savannah Georgia oh I should
talk about Savannah in a little bit
um but yeah dude
my
I'm just under like remember when
Charlie Sheen was like talking about the
Tiger Blood [ __ ] I was with him you know
Tiger Blood I have Tiger Blood I was
with him but when Kanye now Kanye is
just above the part where I just I can't
anymore
I can't anymore
I I like he's just talking about like
like the things I love what Kanye does
is when he gets interrupted by Pierce
Morgan he goes
now you interrupted me right and I'm
just like dude you're speaking my
language man that's basically just
singing oops okay so Kanye got that from
me all good Kanye stole from me it's
fine okay
but then when and then when and then
when [ __ ] um Pierce Morgan says
you're a billionaire Kanye West goes
multi you're speaking my language dude
okay you basically got it from me
all right
so I'm just like okay I'm I'm bored with
that [ __ ] but then when you say you're
Jewish
I have a problem with that
see I would drop them oh man Adidas is
just going like Adidas hasn't dropped
them yet as of now of me recording this
but indeed it's every time someone drops
them Adidas is just like
[ __ ]
we're about to be out [ __ ]
a billion dollars and then Kanye hello
Millions
[Music]
if you'd like to make a oh wait if you'd
like to make a message C5
whatever dude we lose our minds
um
yeah dude Adidas has just got to be
[ __ ] just like let's just see you
know we think what he's doing is wrong
but look Adidas is for sure like if we
get you if he's getting juice it's just
let's look at the sales okay
if you know yes people put out on the
freeway Kanye was right about the Jews
and yes he's spreading hate but we want
to sell some 350s look we get it but
Yeezy season 12 is coming and
uh
I'm not gonna stop wearing them you know
people are like throwing their Yeezys
away and [ __ ] I'm wearing them
and I love Jews I love Jews
um
yeah but I was in on a plane watching
that [ __ ] and I was laughing out loud
too like it's sad because he's got
mental problems I think that there
should be a thing if you have mental
problems anything you say shouldn't be
used against you at all
you know what I'm saying
um because your brain is broken
like if you're [ __ ] if you've got no
arm and it's harder to pick something up
people aren't like come on [ __ ]
you're like oh the guy's got one arm
okay well you know it takes as long as
it's gonna take
this is how Kanye is it takes as long as
it's gonna take figuring out that the
Jews aren't bad
he's basically [ __ ] got one arm in
his mind
wow a [ __ ] uh
uh what do you call it Jack Johnson song
I've got one arm in my mind or no what's
that [ __ ] uh
uh who's that [ __ ]
um God damn it
I've seen fire and I've seen you right
what's it was that guy James Taylor dude
so wait
um name is James Taylor um so uh went to
uh dude that's PL I'm telling you I okay
so I went to Raleigh I took Calvin and
Kristen we went to Raleigh and uh she's
from Raleigh and so uh we stayed at her
mother-in-law's house and and we love it
okay her mother-in-law's [ __ ] awesome
one of my favorite people and uh and
dude she decorates that's what Kristen
got it from and I'm like oh every time I
go back I'm like oh when I see her house
it's close to Halloween I'm like oh dude
she has like [ __ ] [ __ ] that says like
uh uh uh broom flying lessons
appointments sign in and it's just like
a tablet on the [ __ ] then you're like
dude like you just bought this you know
hey there's no Brew there's no [ __ ]
broom flying like what do we call it
with witches
and then I look into there was like it
was like I only a pillow with like I
only play golf on days that end in y and
it's like dude you know and then in your
head you're like Monday Sunday Tuesday
all the days
oh yeah all of the days
and just like CR there was one thing
where dude and then I sat down in a
chair and I look at my shoes just
because like I put my head down and
right next to my shoes are witch's shoes
and I'm like what the [ __ ] did you put
[ __ ] witchy shoes on the end of her
[ __ ] chair legs dude she had witch
shoes Honor on her [ __ ] chair legs my
my [ __ ] my uh my headphones went up
for a second and I'm just like Jesus
Christ man
so I saw that I laughed and then I made
a [ __ ] witch appointment about a
flying appointment
but like insane dude and so now I'm like
okay so that's what it is like but
Kristen well surpassed the teacher I
mean Kristen is like Kristen goes like
this they're like oh when you want to
[ __ ] when you want to decorate for
Halloween hormones like what do you want
to decorate for Halloween and Krista
goes like this
what's Halloween let's hear those sleigh
bells Ringling too just [ __ ] tossing
out Garland she goes like we get ready
for Christmas [ __ ] come on it's lovely
weather for a sleigh ride together with
you and you're like not in August though
it isn't
shitty before the podcast I'm
lightheaded after I do stuff like that
you go like what what are we having for
Thanksgiving you want to put up like one
of those like uh things that look like
uh
we getting gourds we're getting gourds
and you're gonna put out some [ __ ]
orange [ __ ] and Kristen goes like this
[Music]
what's Thanksgiving dude
that's what she goes like here's my
impression to Christmas here's my
Crescent of Kristen wow [ __ ] that up
Riley never mind not doing it um
uh yeah so I was in Raleigh we were in
Raleigh and Calvin was [ __ ] cool as
[ __ ] dude it's so funny he's starting to
say like just like all sorts of [ __ ]
like I love you Daddy and stuff and I
just love him so much and it's cool
slept with him with him in the bed and I
always wondered like if babies like
um
dream and [ __ ] and they were both asleep
and Calvin was in between us uh and uh
Kristen was asleep and Calvin I was like
what I wonder what like a baby's first
Dream is
and then like
like babies don't talk in their sleep
because they don't know words so it's
like I wonder what like if they do that
and then sure enough he he [ __ ] goes
he's sleeping and he just and I'm
watching him like I'm not even asleep
yet and he just goes like this
sweeping I swear to God it was so
[ __ ] funny like dreaming about what
he's doing
sleeping
just completely dreaming that's like
he's like a [ __ ] white chick eating
sushi that's always talking about
[ __ ] eating sushi other times or if
or like an old or older white dude
smoking a cigar talking about how many
cigars they [ __ ] what the kind of
cigars they like could you be more
boring so but when you sleep it's good
to be boring when you sleep because
sleeping is boring that's why you're
sleeping during it
um
so then we went to Savannah Georgia and
it's like dude Savannah Georgia I really
you know what the [ __ ] best places
are when the best cities are the cities
where you're like oh yeah it's so white
but then also you're like wait a second
though it's actually so black
do you know what I'm talking about like
the most stereotypical of both of the
races
are in Savannah Georgia it's unreal dude
like literally just dudes in those
[ __ ] salmon shorts
Sports
or like
say my dad is a lawyer we already know
you know
when you wear those shorts you don't
have to say uh
we go on boats we know right and so
and then like the so the white dudes
will be wearing that with that with with
like a [ __ ] like um
what are those what's that material
that's like
shot nah [ __ ] I don't know
and then a black dude will come by and
be like hey hey where where are you from
you're from a um
what do you do like you you act on a TV
and you're just like the white this most
stereotypical white dudes and the most
stereotypical black dudes make the best
cities dude that [ __ ] was on and popping
hey you where you come on a TV
you know
hey what show you come out on and you're
just like huh
some black guy came out to be like he
said hey will you come out on and I'm
like huh he said you came out on what
show and I'm like uh what
damn where are you from to another
stand and then I'm on the other side of
me I got a [ __ ] a white dude with a
visor on and a and salmon shorts
and like shoes with no socks on and I'm
just like Savannah's [ __ ] it rips
dude it's so dope and so
dude and I was in Savannah and that town
is [ __ ] amazing dude it's so nice
it's so touristy
and um
yeah we had a good time at Savannah and
then we went out and on the uh on the
streets and we were just like chilling
and like uh we got a burger and we were
in line and it was [ __ ] cool and then
some guy was talking to me and spit in
my mouth while he was talking to me by
mistake and it was really cool
[Music]
and you spit in my mouth and I go like
well I'm just like sitting there talking
to him he's just talking he's so drunk
and I go oh like he's dude he spit in my
mouth and I just go oh and and he goes
sorry man and then his girlfriend came
and got him and like pulled him away and
I was like thank God you did that thank
God you did that but I took a flight
from so I left Kristen and Calvin in
Raleigh to hang out with their family
more and I had to do Savannah and then I
flew home and dude when I flew home I
[ __ ] you know I play Wordle right
like I kill it at Wordle I got like 96
on world I've only not gotten it one
time and it's crazy but like not many
people know that because I don't sign in
and share it because I'm not about that
[ __ ] bragging life if I'm very good
at Wordle and so uh the guy next to me I
look over and he's playing Wordle and I
had already done Wordle and the Word was
mummy but he had no idea obviously and
he's trying to work it out and the first
word he checked was M something so he
had the m and then he got the MU and
then he got the MU and then nothing and
nothing and why and he had two guesses
left dude and he tried Mugsy which was
wrong because it was mummy and then he
had two guesses left and and dude the
guy tried to write the word moxie
with two x's
tried it twice
and it shook because it's not a word and
tried it again like the thing was wrong
and I was like if this guy doesn't get
mummy dude and then he was like
m-u-m-p and I'm just like dude
and that was when I realized
he [ __ ]
was sniffing
and
dude
the guy next to me was sniffing so much
during the flight and thank God I only
realized it two hours left in the flight
because the flight was four hours and 30
minutes if I had noticed it before then
I I I would have snapped dude there were
two times where I was almost like hey
man you gotta blow your nose huh
oh what's up dude just plug it up right
I would just plug it up though yeah
yeah like it's bad enough you can't get
mommy but you're gonna be sniffing every
[ __ ] dude I'm telling you it started
three to six times a minute by the end
of the flight it was I'm not joking 12
times a [ __ ] minute dude when he
every time he would just go it was a
lightning and I'm like even the CBD
can't cure that a lightning rod I think
it was the mummy thing and then with
that the lightning rod of anger dude
I'll just blow it I'll just blow it
and I [ __ ] let me see if I could find
these texts because bro it was so
[ __ ] funny man
it was so funny because I was like I I
had to get I had to
vent because I didn't want dude you know
why I'm good I'm good because of this
and I'm going to tell you why I'm good
and you're gonna listen I'm going to
tell you why I'm good okay because
um I would I was telling
I was so mad oh God I really gotta chill
but I was so mad and um
yeah here we go here we go that I was
like let me text the chain group chain
about it because you know I get [ __ ]
Wi-Fi because no I get a you know I get
Wi-Fi on the floor it costs [ __ ] 29
bucks but [ __ ] no deadliest so
um
I I so I texted my friends
this is this is actually so this is what
God so if I didn't realize how funny it
was gonna go but [ __ ] my anger was
subsiding and I found a way to exercise
it in a different way and I I and then I
just sparked a joy in myself so you can
get through anything really if you put
your mind to it but I wrote to the guys
my God this guy next to me is sniffing
three to six times a minute it's driving
me mental and it doesn't even seem like
he needs to that was the other thing too
it wasn't like he was going and it was
juicy like okay I get it he's sick but
he wasn't sick dude he was just sniffing
and I know you're probably like well
maybe he had a tick but he didn't do it
he didn't and I'm not a doctor but I
know it wasn't a tick because the guy
was so regular and he just kept checking
ESPN and watching a [ __ ] movie with
Sean hadassy so I was like dude he
doesn't have a tick
I don't know what the movie was do I
couldn't figure it out but I look at
people's phones when I'm next to them I
know you could probably tell that by now
but
um so I write and so then I I let it go
and then I write now it's like 12 times
a minute I'm dude I'm going crazy I'm
afraid I'll snap at him I wrote him I
wrote the text chain that because I
didn't want to snap at him right
and then somebody said Hannah I'm a a
little tissue and I said yeah like
[ __ ] blow it
and I said I noticed about two hours ago
I said not sure if it was the whole
flight but it had to have gotten worse
um
and then I wrote Oh My and then I wrote
I'm gonna text one every time he does it
so you know okay
and I write one one my buddy writes I'm
dying I write one my buddy writes haha
nice Jesus I write one one he says it's
too long a flight to not ask him I write
one one he says is this first class I
say yeah even though I shouldn't ask
that because he knows then I wrote one
he said yeah you got to say something
and and then and then [ __ ] my friend
my average friend is like oh you're
still flying this late I said Mark yeah
you know this isn't about that like
stick with the program also like what
what I'm what are you I'm saying one I'm
next to the guys like what does he think
so again I write one because he snipped
again
and he says we're and then I just said
we're Landing one one and he says just
slap him as you land and I write and I
write one and he says you should make a
noise every time he does it now that is
a great gangster move dude
if he just and I go oh
oh
oh like that's gangster but it was too
late and we were Landing
um
one and I could you imagine sitting next
to this one
he says earful my friend says earphones
maybe I said I have them dude he was
breaking through this here's the other
thing too I lost my
I lost my I bring two airpods airpods
are [ __ ] hey fall out of my pocket
more make them rounder you know first of
all make them so they don't fall out of
your pockets they want you to they want
you to say I told you I've been ahead of
I've been in conspiracy before this is
Apple the Apple products this is they
want you to follow they want to follow
your pockets because so that's why they
make them all sleek and [ __ ] and round
so you get to buy new ones and guess
what I do to beat Apple at their own
game when my [ __ ] head when my
airpods fall out of my pocket
I don't even try to look for him I lost
them I try a little bit I go where is it
I duck in the airplane I go under the
seat of the airplane guess what dude
they're gone
they're gone I don't let Apple get the
best of me they don't make me that angry
plus I'm using all my anger for the
sniffer right so I I just go into my
backpack I take out other airpods and I
you know what that is game tax when you
lose your Apple products that's game tax
when the [ __ ] airpods fall out game
tax dude and of course I want I I wear
the [ __ ] Slide the side pockets so
it's easier to fall out but that's
fashion dude I don't want to I don't
want the pockets on the like the Jean
pockets
are you guys with me on this you know
what I mean if you're listening let me
know in the comments but anyway so I
took out my other ones and I didn't have
the noise canceling on these so I'm like
I have the earphones and I still heard
the [ __ ] so I write one okay [ __ ] man
one I'm going nuts gotta land
then I'm like
then they say
uh record him and I'm like what a great
[ __ ] idea
so I'm like I'm gonna record this dude
and all I have to do is
put my head near his head
because I got the airpods in right I
don't have to put the phone over near
his head I have to because I was like oh
that's gonna be obvious but then I'm
like I just lean over
and he was watching this [ __ ] Sean
Addison movie and I'm just leaning over
with my earphones and I'm and I'm
hitting the record button
and he's doing it so much that I get him
so here is him sniffing
here here's him sniffing
okay you heard it it's okay so you heard
it dude all right now that's not that
loud but it's too loud period if you
could hear it on my airpods okay so he's
dude the extra time in the beginning you
know here
there it is dude all right now that's
too loud okay uh so I write you can hear
at the end I'm dying that's him not me
so then I said oh insane whoa he just
did a big one wanna hear another and
they say yeah and another guy says 100
and I go
there you go
that's me saying you're looking
all right cool so I wanted him to hear
me say that a little bit
my buddy says oh man this is hilarious
this is a loud one I got him again
this is so funny
look the flight attendants
it's a long build up but it's good the
payoff is excellent
here we go here we go it's coming up
foreign
unbelievable dude that is so loud
I'm gonna call one in the beginning
I got two on this one
this is the [ __ ] I do man I'm 42. but
this is okay so there's a little one in
the beginning it's really way in the
beginning and then there's one at the
end here
there
oh you heard that one there you go
here comes another one
let's wait for another
there it is dude so annoying bro when
you realize that dude it's like water
torture you heard it right
um I I said wow I'm fuming thank God
this is fun now okay and then
I did
something that was that they don't know
and they don't listen to this podcast so
they're not gonna know but do it
I did something so I could have so much
fun
and and and I I did a Sniff and I did it
really loud and I said oh my God he
looked at me after this one and it was
so big
okay that's me
[Laughter]
but the other ones were his and I said
let me get real close I hope he doesn't
catch me and they said oh he looked at
me
bro they thought it was him right here
look how loud
dude think about me just in my thing in
my like seat like doing this you know
dude like also like people on the flight
some of the people knew who I was or
like Chris I'm just like crystally is
just sitting there recording himself
gonna go
and like laughing afterwards
wow dude I love doing [ __ ] I love being
a [ __ ] dumb idiot dude life rips I
love it dude
I love it man
they still think it's him don't tell him
don't tell those guys
um
God I love it
so yeah so that's what's up that's about
with the flight wow we talk about the
[ __ ] hard-hitting issues here at this
podcast
um
let's go do this here deserve it scales
are these new ones
walking on wet rocks here we go
walking on wet always a bad idea
what could go wrong cool internet's
[ __ ] caught great not working yes
dude oh this is amazing [ __ ] God damn
it I hate when this okay it's okay dude
I'm good I'm good we're good we're
hanging out having a good time I don't
want people to think that like I'm
really not a curmudgeon I'm a nice
person if you come up to me
I really am don't don't come up to me
though
here we go
the girl knew women's tuition women's
intuition tuition women's wow I mean
just zero react reaction from the wife
just reacted all before and then just
don't walk on wet on wet cement man
oh dude tailbone out of commission
oh man that hurt dude oh it just got me
we need to get that on the [ __ ]
soundboard
um yeah that guy hurt that sucks I've
done that before but not on wet rocks my
god dude that deserved scale is a seven
Russian Rambo attempting to break bottle
with his head oh well how is this
anything but a 10.
oh sure
wow
so drunk huh
get out get the [ __ ] out that's not real
get the [ __ ] out he knocked himself out
like that hold on a second let's watch
this again I mean like he's like a Daffy
Duck cartoon
not sure
the biggest
idiot in the world dude
wow this is like [ __ ] he went down
like Tua
no that's that's that looks
it's got to be fake
he's
It's gotta be fake right because you
wouldn't be able to break that over your
head I guess you could
also he would fall forward right
maybe not okay
or shorts of all time
like
I don't know man this guy's in the
that's crazy to either way if you faked
that
it doesn't even it doesn't matter dude
the way he fell was so painful you know
okay trying to cruise through a flood oh
I love it car's gonna get stuck right
that that deserve it skills is an eight
I mean he wanted to do it
look this guy thinks he's got the oh the
all-new
Nissan what is it a Nissan what oh wow
that that thing ran right through it the
new Isuzu oh
okay that went through oh oh
dude dude when these hit you uh when
these when you think you're you know
what's gonna happen and something else
happens I think I went through with a
motorcycle like it's a twisted metal
dude oh my god dude I love how they
showed two dude that's what these need
to be yo you need to you you know what
the deserve it scales this is what we
figured out dude you need to see the
[ __ ] control first you need to see
what happens successfully first and then
the cack I mean dude just the all-new
Nissan [ __ ] four-door SUV
get through beautiful water and it's all
good Nissan the all-new Isuzu Trooper
getting through water just like the
Nissan the all-new Isuzu Trooper we go
everywhere the all-new Suzuki oh my God
he [ __ ] died his [ __ ] came out of his
anus a little bit
wow dude
worst motorcycle commercial
the Suzuki all right here we go
I gotta log in for that one what does it
show tits I don't I don't have a Reddit
[ __ ] it we'll go to the next one
I couldn't see it it's so good
all right here we go
trying to jump over a series of chairs
now this is always great white only
something white dudes do by the way
nobody would do this but white dudes I
was so white the first the first the
first [ __ ] listen the first
so why dude no dude
that's the whitest [ __ ] of all time dude
no
oh
dude I love that man
the [ __ ] nine beers in you know all
right
nine eight
seven six five this is the best shot
I've ever seen in my life by the way
this shot is so Fellini see this and you
go like oh why did I not think of a
doctor why did I not think of another
shot this is the most beautiful shot
I've ever seen in my life does the guy's
head like this wow it's amazing here we
go one
dude the way
oh so that's wine dude dude the way he
fell dude of course there's a foosball
dude this is a whole thing is actually
the whitest thing of all time it's
unbelievable what they're wearing they
got foosball they thought this was a
good idea they've got so many wines and
[ __ ] Chargers on the table
wow
no
and a ping-pong table dude this is the
whitest thing I've ever seen in my life
the deserved scale is off to 10. it's a
ten the chandelier wow this is the best
shot I've ever seen in my life
didn't even get one chair
let's do it also what was the goal the
chairs went all the way to the foosball
table
dude this is a 10. this is unbelievable
we gotta watch it again
right turn
nice this is phenomenal
seven six five four three
two
one
oh why did he slide so much dude what
was the goal I I I I gotta know this guy
what was the goal let's look at the
comments even if you would have jumped
over all those chairs he gave himself
absolutely no space yeah exactly dude
that's hold on
it's even if you made it he would have
smashed into the Foosball table what a
dunce dude that's so great well somebody
just said Honestly by screwing it up
it's time to go to the table you might
have accidentally saved himself I'm
kidding
dude that's so funny why I wish I
thought of that
oh my God that's amazing
that's a 10. wow it's rare we get a 10.
but that's so great everything was so
white the wines the Chargers on the
table the Foosball the ping-pong table
the [ __ ] way they were dressed the in
the beginning and when the guy went Roy
and then the fact that they thought that
they could do it the whole the widest
thing of all time dude
the widest thing of all time
unbelievable the chandelier from the
chandelier to the [ __ ] idea that they
could do it the whitest thing of all
time wow
wow unbelievable I'm so lightheaded
after that dude I should not do this
podcast when I haven't eaten I ordered
food while I was I ordered a food during
the break while I was going to the
bathroom because I'm disrespectful like
that but really I'm respectful
I love you guys man thank you so much
all right here let's go to some [ __ ]
Tinder things man wow that was amazing
here we go hi
if you have if you just high with uh
more than one eyes you know you're you
know it's on and popping somebody says
are you a bank loan because you have my
interest wow person says I like that one
and then the guy says I'm gonna be up
front you have nice boobs
you know
pushed it a little too hard there boobs
also like you know don't say boobs
honestly it could have worked way better
if you said yo can I be frank them
titties are banging
nice boobs one time a girl told me that
a guy was having sex with her she's
having sex with a guy and the guy goes
like this while they're having sex oh
awesome and I dude and I think about
that all the time that is so funny
dude imagine having sex with her he was
having sex with her
and he just goes ah awesome
well he's on top of her too so good
so good
um here's another one maybe being single
isn't so bad it says uh what are you up
to your pictures are gorgeous the guy
says and she says haha thank you I'm
just working how about yourself and then
oh my god dude the guy says [ __ ] you
stupid [ __ ]
oh dude
so many problems
I mean what a dick
wait okay oh amazing that it was Monday
at one at two a.m he says hey what are
you up to your pictures are gorgeous
then a day I guess
that day at 3 P.M she says I think
you're just working and then at 6 13 a.m
he says [ __ ] you stupid [ __ ] you know
just woke up so mad oh no I'm wrong side
of the bed who the [ __ ] thinks [ __ ] you
stupid [ __ ] when you wake up
sorry I didn't have my coffee yet
I mean what did he want her to say here
we go
are your parents Bakers because they
made a cutie pie and then she says your
dog that's what he said and then your
dog said she says your dog is cute
unlike the owner oh wow that's a dick
he says okay
um
well people are so rude
they're so rude oh dude there was a guy
who got on my [ __ ] flight
and he was so drunk
there was a guy on my flight and they I
actually have never seen this before
uh uh he was so drunk that they didn't
let him on the flight oh he was a mess
oh I felt bad for the guy too dude he
was so drunk that he was trying to get
on a flight and he was like wobbling a
little bit and they're like here stand
over here start standing over here
sir stand over here and he was like what
and he walked over to the [ __ ] place
where she said stand over here and then
they let us pass because there were like
nine people in front of us and finally
we went we got past the guy and she said
sir what's your
he was so drunk dude she said sir what's
your um what's your what's your final
destination and he literally said where
where you want me to go I'll go
where you want me to go where am I
supposed to you tell me where I'm
supposed to be he said and I was like oh
and then she says okay Sarah we're not
we can't let you get on the plane in
this state
like
and I thought it would be it would have
been so good if he said you mean North
Carolina
what state do I have to go to dude he
was so drunk and he he was so drunk that
he didn't even give a [ __ ] he just kind
of like walked away he was so pink face
dude he was a white guy and he was so
pink face and he had shorts on and a
long sleeve shirt dude that's the
drunkest outfit of all time
shorts on a long sister and the [ __ ]
uh see-through like [ __ ] not Crocs
but like the leather ones
wow and he was like 55 so sad Alone um
here's somebody here's another
deservancy a small P what
it says well looking for a relationship
or besties single mom I like bad boys
small peen swipe left
I want to ride on your motorcycle oh
she's definitely good looking
small peen swipe left
you know
you know they say like big dick dudes
have a lot of really confident energy
because it all comes from the dick but
like dude you know how confident you got
to be if you got a small dick I feel
like guys who have a small dick like you
could probably have the most
best confidence because of how small
your dick is because you have to have
[ __ ] killer confidence
look my shit's [ __ ] so long of course
I have [ __ ] you know confidence
but like if you have a really small one
like so small that it doesn't even go
down it just like perks up like it's
just looking at you
like you got to be like you know what
[ __ ] it I'm the [ __ ]
like they like girl like like you know
like chicks can't even give you like
stroke jobs they gotta Like This Is How
They jerk you off like this
look it's a like it's a bean
look at tickle it okay obviously we're
gonna get age restricted here
um
dude you ever have a buddy that's
[ __ ] that his penis is so small that
like his girlfriend like this
this is how you give them head like this
wow
we love it dude congratulations is the
best practice around why are we at 596
subscribers it's absolute [ __ ]
it is what it is though man it you know
what's actually so cool about this
podcast God I love you guys man we're
we're a group you know what I mean and
then when you come to my shows and I see
you with the [ __ ] tattoos and the
merch and all that [ __ ] and when I see
you just there man like we did 2 300
people in Raleigh and we did a uh I
think I sold 1900 tickets in Savannah
um but like dude
you guys are just I [ __ ] love you man
[ __ ] love you man
and I get to see my son and you know
life rips man I get to see my son soon
he lands I actually probably landed
um
I have to eat my food quick before they
get here because I didn't order them
anything and I feel bad get rid of all
the evidence dude you ever do [ __ ] like
that
like you're just like I don't want to be
selfish I'm like if I could just do it
quickly I could be selfish
I ordered food and I didn't I got a
sandwich that I think maybe she'll like
but I don't know if she will and I'm
kind of insecure about it so I'm just
going to order the food I ordered the
food I'm gonna eat it real quick hide
all the remnants and then later on I'm
gonna sneakily be like would you want a
chicken sandwich there's one in the
fridge
my mind is so [ __ ] warped but it's
all good my babies
um well I'm legitimately talking about
nothing but here's the deal dude you
guys you ride with me man and that was
what was gonna be my point like I'm so
fortunate in life and I love my life and
I love my family and I just my [ __ ]
friends that rock with me and the
[ __ ] fans man this is a cult and
we're gonna just ride it out and we're
not gonna we're gonna it's not one of
those end of the world Cults it's not
even really a cult we just chill and
hang out and share ideas and one day
we're gonna build this log cabin and
it's gonna be absolutely beautiful man
um but I love you guys man and thanks
for listening I'll be in Denver I'll be
in Phoenix I'll be in Seattle I'll be in
Lakeland Florida I'll be in all sorts of
places and Portland
um in New York we just added another
show it's insane thank you very much New
York uh and Chicago uh so get your
tickets at chrysalia.com get your life
rips merch uh or come to a show and get
your [ __ ] uh exclusive merch and wear
the merch to other comedians see this is
the thing dude this is how we Infiltrate
The ideas and infiltrate Society where
the merch to other comedian shows this
is the [ __ ] thing man represent that
Life represent that life rips lifestyle
man that's it for the YouTube episode if
you want to catch the raw uncut unedited
version of the uh patreon then go over
to our patreon episode and sign up for
our patreon uh patreon.com crystalia and
you can get all of the extended episodes
uh and you can also get all of the
episodes that are only on patreon and so
far we have like 17 or 18. so so uh go
get it patreon.com crystalia and get
that uh right now and for for only six
bucks I appreciate you guys and thanks
very much for listening
[Music]